The next question on this homework is to implement login.
Let me give you a demo of what this is going to look like.
I am at this URL\login.
After doing the register portion of this homework, the first part, this is going to be very simple.
Basically, it's a similar form to the registration except it only has a username and password.
If you type in a valid username and password and hit submit,
it redirects you to the welcome page.
It sets the cookie, and it takes you to the welcome page.
If you were to type in an invalid password or a username that doesn't exist,
you get an error message that says invalid login.
Only when you type in a valid username and password do you get redirected
to the welcome page. Mm-kay? Cool.
This welcome page has the same cookie that I had before.
That gets set on a successful login.
When you have this working, submit the URL here. Good luck with this one.